you are looking into a campaign about
military housing what's the idea well
the basic premise is that everyone who
serves in our Armed Forces should be
living in a decent quality home but we
know that Armed Forces personnel and
their families are living on military
bases and in the community in military
housing that is leaky with leaky roofs
broken boilers and black mold in
bedrooms now this problem has been
getting worse over recent years with
private contractors hired by the major
defense paid a fortune but not repairing
these properties and that is leading
directly to people feeling that they
want to leave the services but at this
very moment we need a stronger set of
armed forces and with one in four Armed
Forces Personnel saying that poor
accommodation is increasing their
intention to leave the Armed Forces
that's a really serious problem that we
need to get to grips with and what
Labor's been saying is the 13 years of
Tory government have not got to grips
with it but the next Labor government
will make this a priority so we can fix
it so every one of our Armed Forces and
their families get to live in a decent
quality accommodation military
accommodations obviously in the news
today as well because the government is
talking about potentially housing
migrants in disused military sites
do you think that's a good policy well I
don't think it's going to work because
fundamentally it doesn't fix the
problems with our immigration system I
didn't ask if it was going to work but
in principle do you think it's a good
policy it's good enough for soldiers is
it good enough for people who come to
our Shores trying to claim Asylum well
they're not being used for the
literature at the moment so they're not
moving soldiers or RAF Personnel out of
a Barrack blocks and moving Asylum
seekers in in many cases these are bases
that have been closed for many years and
might be used for different purposes in
the meantime but it doesn't deal with
the fundamental problem in the fact that
the Asylum system is broken it takes too
long for decisions to be made in fact
actually we know the number of decisions
about Asylum cases is actually falling
with a really slow response rate so that
means that we're not able to either
Grant Asylum for those people who have
an eligible case fast enough or
importantly remove those people who
don't have an eligible case because we
haven't got return agreements with our
nearest neighbors France and the rest of
the European Union and the government's
not being tough enough on those criminal
gangs so it's dealing with the
consequences of broken policy rather
than trying to fix it at source which
they really should be I'm just trying to
get my head around whether you disagree
with the government's policy in
principle or if you just think the
implementation is wrong so it's the
speed at which the applied Asylum system
uh is is working or whether or not it's
about whether you can get a returns
agreement uh in place with countries
around the world at our nearest
neighbors as well or is it in principle
do you think that look we should be more
welcoming towards as Island Seekers we
should be letting more people in which
is it well at the moment we have had too
many Asylum Seekers and not enough
accommodation for them so there has to
be a way of housing people that are
coming to the UK and claiming Asylum but
the fundamental problem is wherever you
put them if you're not having an
immigration system that can make
decisions sensibly and last year they
made a decision only one percent of
Asylum cases so this isn't about a
marginal gain here and there this is
about a fundamental failure of the
government to make proper decisions on
Asylum cases and no matter how much
tweaking around the edge and dealing
with the consequences of a broken system
if you don't get to the root causes
that's the criminal gangs that are
profiting from those dangerous Crossings
across the channel and the fact that the
government can't make quick enough
decisions to have a system that works or
what Labor's arguing is that we should
be fast tracking those people that are
claiming Asylum from safe countries
Albania for instance by fast tracking
those decisions you could be clearing
much of the Asylum backlog so you can
actually then be spending the time on
those cases that do deserve proper
scrutiny and proper support for those
individuals that are fleeing war and
conflicts that's not where we are at the
moment so this looks to me like just
another headline grabbing initiative
which is there to divert attention from
the fact that the system is
fundamentally failing where do you think
people should be housed then what they
shouldn't be housed in um in hotels
because that is far too expensive for
the public it doesn't provide the
support and certainty for the people who
have fled war and famine and so
realistically you can we can have an
argument about where the huge numbers of
people should be housed now and there is
probably a case for looking at different
varieties I'm not convinced putting
people on a barge is the right answer so
not hotels not barges what's the idea
then where should they go but the way to
deal with that is by dealing with the
backlog is by processing the claims
they've got to go somewhere in the
meantime though haven't they well in the
meantime they are going into hotels we
know from the government announcement
yesterday that those people who served
with our armed forces in Afghanistan who
have been given sanctuary in the UK who
are in hotels currently are going to be
evicted by the government in three
months time but that's not the same
Focus uh policy they're applying to
Asylum Seekers so it seems that if you
serve with our Armed Forces you're
getting a rougher deal from this
government than if you came over on a
small boat because the system's not
working to process those claims I mean
this is a mess Sophie and that's the
fundamental problem on this if we don't
fix it at source if we don't uh help
keep more people in their countries by
making safer Arrangements creating safe
routes so people with a genuine case can
legally come to the country and then
have their claims processed not in many
years but in a small number of months
which is what we should be aiming for
well that would clear up the backlog
that would reduce the impact on
communities and last night in the
comments labor tabled amendments to the
legal immigration bill that would have
allowed local communities to have a
bigger say on that extra temporary
accommodation in their own communities
now Tory MPS voted against that but now
we have Tory MPS who are finding out
today that their own communities are
having additional Asylum Seeker
accommodation placed on former military
sites where their communities get no say
it doesn't seem that the system's
working and we spoke to Jillian Keegan
the education secretary a little bit
earlier on the program and she was
talking about the offer made to teachers
she thinks it's a reasonable one she
also said that people shouldn't worry
parents shouldn't worry about school
funding because the additional money
that was given in the Autumn statement
is she right well I would like people
not to worry about their kids education
because after the years of disruption we
know that our kids have suffered quite a
lot but the Press pressures that
teachers are under the cost of living
crisis it really means that teachers
have a valid concern about where they
are and I think ministers need to sit
down much more with them well they have
been sitting down with them haven't they
they haven't really got anywhere right
but to sit down there's a simple Act of
sitting around a table and there's the
act of sitting down and genuinely
listening and trying to find a solution
offer more money to teachers well I
can't make spending commitments
especially this far out from a general
election but I think what the government
could be doing is genuinely listening to
the case and trying to find a solution
here in the way that they haven't really
been as enthused to do now when
ministers have sat down with unions in
other sectors for instance if they
generally listen if they put away their
Hyperbole and their big stick and say
okay let's have a mature conversation
about how we can resolve this because
teachers and nurses are not the bad guys
it's not just the mature conversation
they want though is it they want money
right that's the stepping point they
have been sitting around the table both
sides have got there on the table and
they just can't agree on money that's a
problem it is
um and that's where good negotiations uh
properly work because in these
situations you resolve strike action by
proper negotiation and that's where
ministers should be around the table
taking the time to understand the true
consequences especially for those people
in teaching who are on low salaries
those people starting out in teaching
For Whom the cost of living crisis is
acutely feltful okay now um this week of
course kostama has waded into a bit of a
round with Jamie Corbin he's been barred
from standing as a labor candidate and I
just want to read a quote to you the
attacks on Jeremy corbyn on the election
we just had were terrible and they came
back at us on the doors they vilified
him and they knew what they were doing
and they knew why they were doing it
Jeremy corbyn being vilified I mean it
feels like that could be a quote from
John McDonnell or diabet about kierstama
recently but that was actually starmer
himself the labor leadership hostings
back in 2020.
I guess my question isn't you know about
rehashing the argument about whether or
not Jeremy corbyn is fit to stand as a
labor MP a question is about care
Starlight because it feels like he's
changed his mind on Jeremy corbyn
despite the fact that everything we knew
about Jeremy corbyn then we know now
yeah
um I think he has made the right
decision here because he's also given
Jeremy the opportunity to apologize for
his remarks around anti-Semitism that
Jeremy chose not to and a route back
into the Parliamentary party if he had
taken it now Jeremy corbyn chose not to
do that I don't think Jeremy's the
future of the labor party I think we've
moved on as a party and labor now looks
unrecognizable from the party that
Jeremy led a few years ago Starman looks
unrecognizable as well then because he
was obviously around the shadow cabinet
table telling everyone that they should
vote for him as the next prime minister
but what's happened since then is we've
had the ehrc report that looked at
anti-Semitism in a labor party that
highlighted the utter failings of our
party to deal with anti-Semitism Kier
said on day one of his leadership that
that would be the don't stick to assess
his leadership against he would take
Serious action that's what he has done
Jeremy had a choice about how to respond
to that animation and I'm afraid he
chose uh poorly and chose to continue
some of those uh some of that language
that has helped uh that was designed to
downplay anti-Semitism well
anti-Semitism should have no place in
low party and no place in politics in
general and if you can't call out
anti-Semitism clearly without without
um without qualifying it then you
shouldn't be a labor MP and that's what
kirs made very clear to all the
Parliamentary party and that's what
laborers national executive committee
have made clear for anyone wishing to
stand as a labor candidate at the next
general election okay thank you for
watching thank you